Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to "Such Scary 2016."
Supposedly the scariest game ever made.
Also it's a horror game, also it's a comedy game -- COMEDY HORROR! Something like that
Hello! [reads text] It's simple.  Take the rock and put it on the pedestal.  Use left mouse to interact with stuff.  Oh, and there's an easter egg in every room.
Is there? I can't see shit!
You talking about this rock here? This glowing possibly irradiated rock?
I'm sure there's nothing that's gonna go wrong with this
♫La-dee-da-dee-frickin'-da-dee♫ Here we go!
Hey! I didn't get the easter egg! Shit! I'm an idiot!
Let's see...
Where's the rock?
Hold SHIFT to run.
I don't know!
Where's the easter egg?
Is that the rock?
How do I crouch?
Oh no, I got it anyway
UHUHUHUHUHUHUH
AHHHHHHAAH!!!
Okay.
I did it! I'm so happy with myself :3
Woah OOH!
uh nugh uh
No, it's not under the table this time.
Oh.
Well then, shit.
I am boneroned.
How am I ever gonna be able to find this rock?
My only objective is to put rock on table!
....pedestal
thing...ooh what's that?
Hey! Ohhhhh
Is that a dick-butt I see?
Oh, it's the pedestal of dick-butt!
*eerie foghorn* *worried Mark is worried*
Oh! Oh, okay
Is it through this door?
squeak indeed....
Hello? Is there a rock in here?
Hang on.
I can't read- *door closes*
Uh oh.
But if it's not here then wh-
Oh, okay.
I see it!  I got it!
Okay, alright then.
Getting a bad feeling about this, but okay.
I did it! I put rock on pedestal!
I'm the greatest!
[reading] But where is the pedestal?
Ah, shit.
Well...
*manly groan*
Through here?
Okie..
Getting a little more...sinister-
Woah, wait a minute.
WOAH WAIT A MINUTE.
HANG ON A SECOND HERE.
Guh..
Ooh, oh you're gonna be like that, are you?
Oh, you're gonna be like that?
Nothing behind the door?
Easter eggs?  I have no idea where they are.
I don't wanna have to go back.
Oh, god.
Hello!?
[reading] You didn't forget the stuff, did you, now?
No, uh, why would I have?
Okay, there's a pedestal over there, but...
Do I just...?
No, okay...
Where's all the easter eggs?
Alright, just gonna go for it.
HA!
Gonna put this dragon egg down here.
I did It!- I did the thing! *Derpy Nerd Voice*
Okay, which way is it?
Uhh, that way?
Is it down there?
Noooe? Okay.
Uh..
Oh, jeez
Helloh?
Ah, shit.
Oh you're gonna be like this?
Oh, god, no.
Oh, no.
If I open both of them, I'll be able to defeat the system!                                               (ง ͠° ͟ل͜ ͡°)ง
In here?
Yeah?
No. That was a lie. (ಥ﹏ಥ)
Ah, Shit. ಠ╭╮ಠ
Hello? ◉_◉
Well these are awfully dark
Anybody in there?.
Huh, is that Dwayne, the Rock, Johnson?
HUH,  I don't think that's the egg I'm look for!
[reading] This is not the-
Oh, this is not the *rock.*
Why did I say egg?
'Cause I'm an idiot.
Alright.
Oh.
Pre-
Fuckin
Shadows!
[reading] -Press button at your own risk.
Okay!
[boom] .O.
Did something happen to The Rock?
Rocky?!
Oh, god, is he okay?  Oh, good, he's okay.
Okay.
So...
Aah, that's good!
Perfect! Okay.
Thank you, thanks for the rock.
Aaaand, shabooski!
Okay, I did that!
Oh, only... 7 more rooms to go.
[reading] A Very Important List: tree, fire, turtle, truck, flamingo, fox, fish, trap.
I'm not gonna remember any of that.   (•_•)
I'm not gonna remember any of that (x2) ( •_•)
*Quieter* I'm not gonna remember any of that (x3)
Okay.
Ah, so, there's buttons here.
So if I were to guess what this meant, I would have to think that these are in order of something
an..and I'm beginning to think it might be alphabetical order?
So if I correspond these to the buttons on the thing, *Sounding so smart its scary*
but I push them in alphabetical order,
so fire would be the first one and it's the second one.
so boink, okay, that makes sense.
Then, flamingo, which would be... the fifth one. Then...
*mistakes are made*
No, aah!
Nope.  Okay so, fire.
Fish.
Flamingo
Fox.
[wall sliding]
[thud]
Heck yes?
okay, then...
[reading] tree, truck, turtle, trap
so, trap would be first
trap,
tree
*Mark's problem solving sound*
Did that do something?
I thought it did something! Something was happening!
awwww something happened...
*Mark's experimenting*
Dang it!
What if I do the other ones...
trap
*contemplating silence*
tree
truck-
[wall sliding noise] YEEAH!
*happy Mark* WOOOOOO!!!
I did it! Okay I just had to do them both separately!
[clenched teeth] ERRUHHHNNN YEAH!
Oh, what's that?
HEY it's a kruber!
[reading] If you see Gordon Freeman, give him this *touches crowbar* Okay :D
Half Life, okay
I get it *sooo funny*
I'll get my egg now,
Go over here...
I DID IT! I did it!
I don't know what the easter egg in the first one would've been
Kay...
[reading] Just go for it, if it doesn't work, turn around and see where that gets you
ohh that doesn't- that doesn't sound good
Oh, that doesn't sound good at all! oh I don't like the sound of that!
*YOU WERE RIGHT MARK*
*I'm always right*
Huh...
ouh...
[reads again] Turn around, see where that gets you
Okay! I'm going for it!
oh, I like this room
*steps are a stimp-stampin'*
Well,
URRRHHNNNN
I don't think- oh, is- is something happening? WHHOOOOAA
I made it! I think...
Did I make it?
OH!
Good! :)
[reading] If it worked last time what could go wrong?
*THUD*
*lamp gets stuck*
Kaboomie?? Okay....
*more stimp-stampin'*
HELLOOO??
Ah! PEDESTAL!
But where is eegg?
Here is egg.
Where is easter egg?
Okay, I don't know..
*realization* THERE WAS A BUTTON! AHHHHHHHHH
Okay hang on,
I need to go back and I need to get the easter eggs in these things
Because otherwise I'm going to hate myself before I get to the end
SO I'M GOING TO GET THE EASTER EGGS
So there's an easter egg in every room.
*really?* So you say...
But I can't see what's in this room...
I can't see nothin' at all...
*found one!* OHH HELLOO!!!
Let's see: [reads] Where is your body?
*Mark is thinking*
Oh. Good- good question!
I didn't even ask myself that! I don't have a body!
I usually don't question when I'm playing first person shooter games...
...first person games, not shooting anything...
Very strange!
VERY STRANGE!
Okay, I need the one in room two.
Hold SHIFT to rrrun
[rolling R's] Wherrre is the rrock?
Let's see: [reads] Jet fuel can't melt steel beams!
OH MY GAWD!!!
*whispers* that's impossible...
*ominous Room 3 is ominous*
Okay, so I think I got the one in room 3
So I need room 4
*ominous room 4 is ominous*
*door creak #1*
*door creak #2*
Okay
Ah, but what happens if I close this...
And then open it up again?
NOTHIN'
Nothin' at all!
oooh...
I forgot my stuff!
I forgot THE stuff!
I forgot THE STUFF!
Put that there, that's good
*discoveries are made*
UH OH, UH OHH! Found it! Found it! Found it!
Found it! What'd I find?
Oh, who is that?
Who IS that?
I don't who that is
Oh that's the creator, okay :)
No wonder I don't know who that is
Uhh, it's nobody! >:3
Alrighty then.
Okay, so now that I'm caught up- oh NO, I'm not caught up
I need to get room 7
How did I not get the one from room 7?
Aw, I thought I did this.
OH yeah,
this is THE one
th- th- than I'll be caught up
*creepy sounds* LET'S GO
huurrrrhhhh
Drop that there for now,
And then: Huh-boom!
*GOTTA GO SANIC FAST*
Sonic!
SANIC??!! Okay, bye Sanic!
Have a good day!
euuhhh
Alright, room 8, now we're getting into the new territory.
[reading hint] Five digits.
Gotta 'em right here, baby! Okay?
Five digits. How am I supposed to know- be able to know what they are?
*MARK LOOK BEHIND YOU*
What was that?
What WAS that?
What was that?!
Something happen?
Something happen over here?!
HUH?!
Alrighty then...
Okay... Oh!!!!
Oh "The cake's not a lie!"
OOOHHH! :0
Well, apparently that is a lie, but not for me!
That easter egg was not well hidden
Okay, so
Pie?? *pewdie?*
Is the pie- *deep inhale*
Pie!!!!!!!!
Okay, so it probably wants the first five digits of π!
*remember?* 3.1415926... *no he doesn't*
Okay- whoops. Nope.
3.14
*success*
YAAAY!
I DID IT!
WHHOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
Okay, anything else here?
Anything else here?
Alright, okay. Good, good, good.
Good, good, good! :)
I'm doing it!
Like I should!
Hey, remember those old cell-phone keypads?
Not at awll...
Not at AWLL!
Uh huh. UH HUH
Ah!
Okay!
I get it!
That's for refer-ance
Which I don't need, because I'm a smarty-pants
*see what I did there?!*
Okay...
What am I supposed to do with this?
Is this gonna kill me?  Is the Ring Girl gonna come out?
HELLOOO??!
Anybody?!
Okay, so I'm assuming if I open this it's gonna be a little bit different out there?
Is that different? I can't tell
Is there anything else in here?
*the Force is with you Mark*
Okay! Found a breathie!
Don't know why I needed a breathie, but... I got it...
Soooo...
*inhale* oooh!
I get it! It's- it's a VHS, which means that I need to put in the numbers for-
V
H
and S
Boink! *I'm so smart*
And I already got the easter egg, so I'm good to go!
Anything else here? Just in case?
Double easter egg?
NOPE!
Okay, we're almost to the end!
Only three more rooms to go
[reading] Just like room 7 but nothing like room 7
Okay
F-Fine then.
Okay...
Soooo...
How is it not like a rrrrroom 7?
*creepy breathing returns*
What are you doin'? Stop brrreeathing on me
Maybe I don't need to turn back, maybe I just need to keep plowin' forward.
Maybe that's the only way to get anywhere around here.
*Stippy-steppies*
Nope!
Ahhh, okay.
What's in here?
Hello! Ohhhhh.
Lots of numbers!
Let's see: [reads] Where do you live?
Well, that's an awfully personal question!
I don't think I wanna answer that!
Kay, where do I live?
What does it mean?
What does it mean, where do I live??
I gotta get another clue apparently, cause I don't know how to answer that.
There's nothing in here!
Maybe if I-
Nope!
Oh!
*again with the breathing!!*
Stop breathin' on ma neck!
Okay, so 10:25, that's easy
So I just need to put
one at 10...
And...
*SLAM* There!
Whoa! Something 'splode!
How did something 'splode?
Sooo....
Ah! This did 'splode!
So in here,
ohhh there's the eggou
Okay, so what I don't have, and how am I gonna be able to juggle both of these
Okay, I don't have the pedestal and I don't have the easter egg
So, I need to do something 'bout that!
We gotta juggle 'em...
Okay, so it's gotta be the- it's gotta be the puzzle of "Where do you live?"
Oh no
OH NO
What's going on here?
OH NOOO
OOH NOO
OHHHH NOOO
UHHH
Oh!
OH! Pixelated pickaxe!
But I didn't even answer the one about where I live
Well that's gotta be the one that leads to the pedestal then,
but I don't know how to answer that in a sequence of buttons...
Oh, here we go!
Oh we're back. okay
It's gotta be through here. So I got to solve this...
"Where do you live?"
Oh!
I no know-
I don't know why that was the one...
but it was....
oh shit... I can't see a god damn thing...
Of course I can't.
I don't know why that one was the one but okay, I'll take it. Okay
It's probably in this room that looked empty...
Yesh sirrr
Yesh sir reiii
Boooommmm
Okay but there's note on the table... isn't there. Yeah, okay.
"Last one, I promise." Okay sure whatever you say
But I don't know where this blewww
Where the hell did this go boooommm?
But not down there, did it? No, that's where the last one blew up so
It's gotta be down this way.
Right? It's got to be. It's got to be!
Oh god no it wasn't, Oh, jeezums okay i'm just  gonna do this blind!
Doin' this blind!
I don't even know if i'm going straight.
"Fudgernutters".
Okay, fine.
*Disgruntled sigh, not unlike a dying baboon.
Oh, what?
No, come on! I wasn't trying to cycle back
I was trying to get the egg!
Oh, gahahadamn you
Damn you!
DAMN YOU!
I'm not gonna go back.
Here we go.
*I can't see anything*
I don't know where I am.
Oh, god. OH
What's that?
Oh, I see it.
It's right theeeeeeeere!
There we go, goddamnit i got through the
Aaaah, i'm willing to bet that if i would've,
*Death screams of King Kong*.
I'm willing to bet that if i had let in, it was like right next to the *more grunts*.
You might need Wikipedia for this one.
Well no I'm not gonna look up wikipedia.
I'm gonna know this with my braaain.
Okay.
Huuuuum
The date that they landed on the moon, was...
Was that...
Ups.
YEEAH, it was 1969!
HELL YEAH, I KNOW MY SPACE STUFF.
IIII KNOW IT
Oh boy, it's gonna be a series of puzzles.
The answer is faster than light.
So...
Not.. nothing.
I can solve it with my brain. (good luck mark)
Okay, so what's is faster than light?
Technically, nothing.
Nothing is supposed to be faster than light.
But I tried zero.
So it's gotta be actually something.
If it's the number of the speed of light, I don't know that, so I'm gonna look that up.
Okay, so the speed of light in meters per second is 299792458 meters per second.
So I'm gonna do one more than that.
Nine.
HEY, OKAY! I got it!
I didn't know the speed of light off the top of my head, how would I have known that?
UHH, is there another easter egg in here?
An eaaasy easter eggg?
Uh-Oh.
*TECHNO MUSIC STARTS PLAYING, AND MARK POOPS IS PANTS*
That scared me.
I don't know why.
Well, at least I got it.
And there's only one easter egg left to go.
So noow, HAAABUSKI!
GAH, I did it
Last room.
Okay, we've got this far, this should be easy right? (RIGHT)
Yeah, you would think so.
One would think, one would suspect.
Oh no.
But I can't crouch.
Oh god.
Oh no.
How do I... Oh loord.
Oh good golly gosh
How do I crouch?
How do I do this?
*Mark squeaks* I can't lift it.
Well, this is a conundrum.
Okay, Imma turn my back, Imma go this way.
Get the egg..
This goes through the wall, which is awfully nice and convenient of it.
But I don't.
The problem is that I don't go through walls... :(
I can't jump, I can't...
Hum!
Ain't this a puzzle!
So I can extend this in my grip.
Any of these walls, not really walls?
Can I walk through any of these walls, or they're transparent?!
Not that one, NOPE.
Can't click on any of these...
OH. HEY. WOW. HEEY!
It put it back!
That's bullshit, I threw it!
I threw that dang thing!
I threw it good.
*EGH*
Okay, well thank you, misterious force that likes to do that.
If I can just...
Angle it better, maybe I can get it right on the thing and that is gonna be good.
*EGH*
Oh, so close.
A little higher.
*EGH*
Dang it. I can't do higher.
I can do higher, I can do this.
Wooow, that one was a close one.
*EGH*
Shit.
Okay..
*EGH*
YEAH, I did it!
HELL YEAH!
But I didn't get the easter egg!
SHIIIT!
*BLABERING* NOOO!
I need that... I need that sweet easter egg.
I need it.
So, the answer must be throwing something else over there.
*EGH*
Ups, no. That didn't come back.
*SUFFERING SCREAMS*
Heeeey!
*AGH*
Shit.
*EGH*
Aggh, that one should have made it.
Damn it.
Damn it. UGH, that was a sissy throw. (It really was Mark)
*EGH*
I can't see now, so I don't have any judge of how far wind up I am.
Oh, fuck off.
*EGH*
FUUCK.
Fucking fuck!
*EGH*
Come ONNNNN!
FUUCK.
Never gonna be able to get this. Maybe from the other side.
*EGH*
NOOPE.
*EGH* NOOPE.
*EGH*
Damn it!
GOD DAMN IT!
*EGH*
*UUURGH*
*Mark is getting angry *
*EGH*
There we go! Got it. Nailed it. Okay.
I did it! And I got all the easter eggs!
That wasn't scary at all!
AH AH AHAH
So it's one of those situations where I see a game online and it's very highly rated.
But it's got a silly name, and a silly concept.
It was pretty interesting, I-I can't exactly say it was a great game..
But to be perfectly honest - Ohh, shadows could have been on high.
Brightness could have been up.
OHHHHHHH
That would have made my life.. SO much easier.
Oh my goodness.
I could have been playing in extreme graphical fidelity.
Oh, that would have been much better!
Ohhhhh, it's lovely here.
Okay.
So anyway, that is "Such Scary 2016".
So, thank you everybody so much for watching, hope you enjoy this video.
I had some fun with one, so..
Thank you again, and as always.. I WILL SEE YOU IN THE NEXT VIDEO.
BUH-BYE!